let's say that i am a producer of wine
and in this axis vertical axis this is
dollars per bottle so 10
40 per bottle and on this axis right
over here i'll have quantity of bottles
i produce per week so let's say that
this is 100 this is 200
300 and then 400. so this is quantity of
bottles
bottles per week
per week and this is dollars per bottle
dollars per bottle so let's think about
the demand curve here the demand curve
for my type of wine we're going to
assume this is highly differentiated
wine the demand curve looks something
like that i'm doing it as a straight
line for simplicity the demand curve
looks like that and since i said
differentiated this is not going to be
perfect competition i have a monopoly in
my type of wine so this isn't the market
for wine generally this is a market for
my wine my wine has won some taste tests
it has this unique flavor and whatever
else and so you can view you can view me
as a monopolistic competitor there's
obviously competition from other wine
labels from other wine producers but my
wine is differentiated and i have a
monopoly in my particular type of wine
and we've done this multiple times if i
have a monopoly in my type of wine we're
talking about the market in my wine then
my marginal revenue curve my marginal
revenue curve will have twice the slope
of this so it will look something like
that and i'll actually keep going
negative after that so that is
my marginal revenue curve and then we
can think about the cost side the cost
side of things my marginal cost
might look something like this
marginal cost or you could even view
that as a supply curve for my wine and
then we can also do average total cost
so the average total cost started off
high we have a fixed cost divided by a
small quantity
but the marginal costs are lower than
the average so the average keeps going
down and down and down and down then
they're equal now each incremental unit
is bringing up the average in cost so
then the average total cost might look
something like that average total cost
and we've seen this show multiple times
if in the near term i kind of i do have
a monopoly here so i would just produce
the quantity where my marginal revenue
is equal to my marginal cost before that
quantity for every unit i'm getting
economic profit economic profit economic
profit if i produce more than that i'm
not getting any economic profit anymore
so i'm going to produce i'm going to
produce this quantity which i know looks
like about 160 units and i'm going to
sell it i'm going to sell it for oh let
me be careful here the price i'm going
to be able to sell it so this is the
quantity that i'm going to be able to
sell the price i'm going to sell it at
go up to the demand curve that point of
the demand curve and it looks like i'll
be able to sell it for about i don't
know 33 dollars a bottle so 33 dollars a
bottle and if we want to think about
economic profit this is the average
revenue per bottle this is the average
cost per bottle so this is the average
economic profit per bottle and i
multiply that times the total number of
bottles and i'm going to get my economic
profit so this area right over here is
my total economic profit and we can
think about how much are the consumers
betting benefiting from it how much
benefit are they getting excess of what
they're paying for it and that would be
this area right over here that is the
consumer surplus
consumer
consumer surplus now let's say i'm just
not happy with this i i see that there's
an opportunity to get even more economic
profit because after all and we've been
talking about this from the beginning
there are people here who are getting
over forty dollars of benefit from my
wine but i'm selling it to them for only
thirty three dollars everything we've
assumed so far is that we're selling all
the consumers are buying something at
the exact same price
but i'm a crafty wine producer and i say
well let me call that into question why
can't i just put a different label on my
exact same wine and sell it to these
people for a different price and so i do
that exact thing i still produce this
exact same quantity i produce this exact
same quantity but the first the first
hundred units of my quantity i put a
different label on it this label says
super fancy wine
super fancy premium the best wine you
ever drank super fancy pre premium wine
it has all of the awards all of the
fancy people who like it i put it in the
best wine boutiques and the best
restaurants with that label although
it's the exact same stuff in the bottle
and i sell that one at forty dollars a
bottle so the first hundred units i sell
at forty dollars a bottle so now my
economic profit on those units remember
i'm producing 150 so my average total
cost is down here my average total cost
is this line right over here so on those
bottles i'm getting this much economic
profit per bottle times these hundred
units i've now increased my economic
profit i've eaten into the consumer
surplus i've taken some of that for
myself and turned it into economic
profit and then the other i don't know
this looks like about 60 or 70 bottles i
just have with the traditional label and
i maybe sell at the supermarket
traditional traditional label and i just
sell it at the supermarket i call it
just you know pretty good wine just so
in case someone who bought it at the
fancy place doesn't see that the pretty
good wine is the exact same thing and
what i've just done here is i've
discriminated i've discriminated amongst
consumers depending on consumers
willingness to pay i've essentially
charged them different prices and also i
guess to some degree based on where they
shop and their gullibility i am charging
them two completely different prices and
this right over here is called this this
is called price
price discrimination
discrimination
and it's a way that a supplier can
essentially take some of the consumer
surplus for themselves eat into some of
that excess excess marginal benefit that
they're essentially giving to the
consumer and turning it into economic
profit